arriba bajo esta tierra rojiza quedaron
los recuerdos de una vida de carlos
pérez nacido y criado en lo que fue
hasta hace poco una próspera aldea
cafetalera y agrícola en el occidente de
honduras que tenía 50 años de vivir en
este lugar verdad yo nunca creí que me
sucediera lo que me sucede estos días
pero primeramente se viene un deslave
cuando la tormenta del eta me da a los
ocho días digamos se viene el lota fue
el que lo vino a destruir la comunidad y
la grossa mente las 500 familias
lograron escapar de la muerte hoy lo
esencial es salvar la cosecha de café y
recoger lo que se puede de las ruinas
bajo los escombros también quedó la
escuela donde el maestro selvin enseño a
160 niños de la aldea de estos niños hoy
se encuentran en albergues se encuentran
algunos padres está alquilando algo
otros se han ido para lugares lejos
donde los niños prácticamente han
quedado sin nada 289 viviendas quedaron
bajo los escombros
después de que esté cerró prácticamente
se partió en dos y arrasó con todo lo
que encontró a su paso este albergue es
el nuevo hogar de unas 50 familias que
viven de las donaciones y el apoyo de
autoridades locales así transcurren los
días con la esperanza de volver a tener
una casa propia pero gracias a dios que
estamos con vida que lo que le hemos
pedido a dios que nos tiene con salud
hasta este momento pero lo que pedimos
por nuestros hijos un techo una casa que
lo más importante para nosotros el paso
de los huracanes esta y otra en honduras
dejaron un centenar de muertos
las pérdidas representan cerca del 50
por ciento del producto interno bruto